when the heaviest of the rains started
falling rivers swelling and flood waters
surging the force of the water took down
anything in its path
including a freight train
this is all that is left of what has
long been a major rail line running
through the town of sumas connecting the
northwest of the united states with
british columbia canada
the loaded rail cars were toppled by the
force of the water the steel tracks
washed away
and in some parts twisted beyond use
some of these rail cars were carrying
products and farm produce
others were loaded with lumber we have a
lot of our
industrial park businesses that rely on
that railway to transport items
whether going to canada or south on the
railway to the other parts of the state
the longer that the railroad is down and
not able to do that transportation
it's just going to hurt the businesses
here that rely on that it's never a good
time for a freight train to derail
but now more than ever
already supply chains are stressed at
the port of vancouver about 75
kilometers northwest of here there is
already congestion with a backlog of
cargo ships and many roads around
vancouver have been washed out
add to that
these train derailments and you've got a
supply chain that went from stressed to
completely broken
[Applause]
rail officials have begun the difficult
task of riding the fallen train cars but
it will take weeks to get the track
completely fixed and likely even longer
for this western corner of the u.s and
canadian border to even get back to
normal
gabriel lozando al jazeera sue mass
washington